♪
KAMALA HARRIS ONCEGAIN TRYING
TO BE THE WORLD'S WORST BOSS
STAFFERS ARE DESPERATELY FLEEING
AS THE VIC PRESIDENCY TURNS
IN A SINKING SHIP.
YET OTHER AID IS BOLTING AFTER
A WEEK OF FLOPS, CRINGEWORTHY
COMMENTS AND ALL-AROUND BAD
NEWS.
COMB CHIEF OF STAFF WILL BE
THE 13THND MOST SENIOR AES
TO G OUT AFTER REPORTS OF A
TOXIC AND ABUSIVE WORKPCE.
IN THE MOST IMPORTANT JOB SHE
WAS PUT IN CHARGE OF THE BORDER,
IS ANOTHER DISASTER.
EVEN DEMOCRATS CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT EXACTLY KAMALA HARRIS IS
DOING ABOUT IT?
>> THE DEMRATIC VOTERS ARE NOT
HAPPAND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
INDEPENDENT VOTERS ARE N HAPPY
ABOUT THIS DECISION.
SO WHORE WE TRYING TO PLEASE?
>> THEYRE NOW DIVIDED THANKS
TO THE ADMINISTRATION BORD
FAILURE.
TH PARTY IS SPLIT OVER
JOE BIDEN'S DECISION TO END
TITLE 42.
AND HE GETS WORSE.
A TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD SOLDIER
HAS DIED AFTER GOING ON A
MISSION TO RESCUE MIGRANTS.
ANTHAT ON A SAD NOTE, LET'S
TALK ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS.
THIS WOM ACTUALLY THINKS THAT
SHE CAN RUN FOR PRESIDENT AND
SHE APPARENTLY IS AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WAS INVOLVED IN A TOXIC
WORKPLACE, ABUSIVE ENVIRONMENT
SHDOESN'T THE REPORTS.
AND YET SHE STILLS IN THEIR
THINK SHE'S DOING A GREAT JOB.
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS WHAT A
SITUATION IS.
SHE'S LIVING IN AN ENTITLEMENT
STATE BECSE SHE WAS HANDED A
NUER OF THINGS WHICH IS JUST A
SULT OF JUST ASKING FOR THEM.
SHE HAS BEEN EMBEDDED BY TH
CALIFORNIA PRESS.
THE NATIOL PSS.
NOTHING ON THE BORDER ISSUE
SHE'BEEN GIVEN THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTTION
DOESN'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THE BORDER.
THEY HAND HER PORTFOLIO FULL OF
ITEMS THEY HAVE AN AGENDA ON
THEY SAY SO DOING SOMETHING BY
POINTING HER TOE IN FRONT OF
IT BUT THENHEY DON'T ASK TO DO
ANYTHING.
I WANT TO TALK AUT THE
NATIONAL ART SOLDIER WHO'S GE
MISSING.
THIS ADMINTRATION HAS VILIFIED
ANYONE FOR BORDER PATROL T
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD, DPS IN
TEXAS SAYING THAT YOU AR R
RACIST, THEY'VE SEHOW HAVE
NEFARIOUS AGENDA WHEN IT COM
TO THE JOBS THAT THEY'RE DOING
TOEFEND THEOUNTRY.
THIS THE KENILWORTH AT THE DOING
ERY SINGLE DAY.
GOING THE RIVER TAKEN OFF THE
BODY ARMOR TO SEE IF THEY CAN
SAVE PEOPLE  NON-AMERICANS WHO
ARE ENTERING THE CNTRY
ILLEGALLY WHO ARE BREAKING OUR
LAWS AND LITERALLY PUTTING THEIR
LIVESN THE LINE EVERY SINGLE
DAAND THERE'S NO STATEMENT FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE, THERE'S NO
CONCN ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THESE PEOPLE AT THE PUT THEM IN
THIS POSITION BECAUSE THEY
REFUSE TO CLOSE THE BORDER.
IN THE STILL DOING NOTHING ON
TIE 42 THERE IS NOW THIS
DEMOCRATIC ARGUMENT NOT TO END
IT PROPERLY JUST AS A TALKING
POINT BECAUSE TITLE 42 HAS ENDED
THEIR RELEASING SINGLE ADULT
MALES INTO E COUNTRY ALL OVER
THE PLE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
DOES NOT DO ANYTHING TO CHANGE
TH.
>> Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT THE
FACT GREG IS THAT YOU HAV
SOMEONE WHO HAS DD WORKING AT
THE BORDER THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND AMERICAN TRYING TO SAY IN A
LEGAL COMING TO THI COUNTRY AND
ILLEGAL WAY.
YOU KNOW THE FRIGHTENING PART OF
IT A IS THAT WE HAVEN HEARD
FROM KAMALA RRIS.
SHE SUPPOSED TO BE IN CHAR THE
BORDER AND THERE'S NO WORD FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE IT'S ALMOST AS
THOUGH IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Greg: SHE REAY IS THE CNM
PLUS OF LITICAL LEADERS.
I WILL SAY ONE SERIOUS THING
OUT THAT.
JOE BIDEN SINGLED OUT A BORDER
PATR AGENT ACCUSING HIM OF
WHIPPING HAITIAN IMMIGNTS THEY
HAD THE INVESTIGATION THEY FOUND
NOTHING THEY NEVER APOLOGIZED HE
NEVER APOLOGIZED TO TH BORDER
PATROLGENT WHY DISNEY SINGLE
OUT THIS HEROISM AT SOME WAS
LIKE SINGLES OUT AMERICAN
CITIZENS TO SMEAR THEM RIGHT?
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THESE EXAMPLES
WE ONLY GOES AFTER WHETHER THEIR
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S, PARENTS AT
HOOL MEETINGS OR THIS.
THAT'S SERIOUS THING IT WOULD
BE NICE IF THEY D SAY
METHING BUT KAMALA HARRIS I
WOND IF SHE EVER NOTICES THAT
EVERYONE IS LEAVING?
THAT WOULD BOTHE ME.
IMAGINE ENTERING A ROOM AT A
PARTY WITHIN 10 MINUTES
EVERYONE'S GONE AND HE REALIZED
MAYBE YOU MIG'VE STEPPED IN
SOME DOG BUT IS IT AFFECTING HER
AT ALL?
THAT SHE HAVE SOMEBODWHO
CONSTANTLY ON LINKEDIN TRYING TO
GET PEOPLEO GO.
I WOULD SAY THIS IF I WASN
UNEMPLOYED DEMOCRAT I WOULD
DEFINITELY TAKA JOB WITH HER
IT'S LIKE VOLUNTEERING FOR A
WAR.
AT A BAR AND SOME HE SAYS YEAH I
WAS IN IRAQ AND THE OTHER GUY
WAIN AFGHANISTAN.
YOU GO YEAH I HAD A TOUR WITH
KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU BECOME A VETERAN OF THE
COMMONAW OCCUPATION.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE MIGHT
BE A WLE GROUP OF FORMER
STAFFERS ANDPECIAL KIND O AA
THAT SHARES THEIR PTS MEMORIES
WORKING WITH HER BECAUSE THERE'S
LIKE 13 NOW.
THAT'S FOOTBALL TEAM CLOSE TO
I THK RIGHT?THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jeanine: EVEN THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
CAN'T COVER THE BORDER IF HE
DROPS THE MANDATES ON MAY 23RD
WHICH EFFECTIVME ALREADY BN
DROPPED BUT THE TRUTH IS YOU'VE
SO MANY WITHIN THE DEMOCRATPARTO
ARE SAYING IT NOW.
WHAT IS PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S
OPTION RIGHT NOW?
>> LET ME FIRST SAY OFFICER THAT
THE BORDER IS PRESUMED DEA I
HOPE THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE
THE FACTS DON'T LOOK GOOD IN MY
PRERS ARE WITH HIM AND H
FAMILY.NOW IMAGINE THE WHITE HOE
SOME SORT OF STATEMENT IN DUE
TIME IF NOT FOR THE SHOW IS
OVER.
I THINK THE PSIDENT'S POLICY
OF THE BORDER HAS TO COME FR
THE WHITE HOUSE.
KAMALA HARRI HAS BEEN PUT IN
CHARGE OF THIS EFFORT AND WERE
HOPEFUL THAT SHE'S ABLE TO
ARTICULATE A POLICY MY
FRUSTRATION HAS BEEN SIMPLY WHAT
IS BEEN TALKED ABOUT AT TH
TABLE A I THINK A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE CURIOUS WHAT WE
DOING AT THE BORDER AND WHAT WEO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM COMINTO
THE BORDER.
NOW THINK THERE IS A
LEGITIMATE ARGUMENT  BE MADE
THAT SOME OF THE POSTURING ON
THE PART OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAS MADE IT LIKELY THAT MORE
PEOP WOULD COME TO THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.WE CAN DEBATE THAT BUK
IS MORE CREDENCE TO THAT BUT I
THINREPUBLICANS WHO WANT AN
ANSWER TO THIS AND NOT JUST THE
POLITICASIDE OF IT OR
LITICAL ISSUE WE HE TO BESERIOUS
GION AND THIS HEMISPHERE.AT THI.
WE SPENT TRILLIO OF THE LT
25 YEARS PREDAD YOU AND
CONGRESS.
STABILIZING OTHER PARTS OFHE
WORLD WHICH WE SHOULD.
WE SNT PENNIES TRY TO
STABILIZE HER OWN HEMISPHERE.
AND WE HAVE TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
THAT IF WE ARE INDEED SERIOUS
ABOUT CONTRLING AND LIMITING
THE NUMBER OPEOPLE TO COME TO
THEORDER.
I HOPE KALA HARRIS GETS OUT A
POLICY FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
HOPE SHE'S ABLTO IMPLEMENT IT
IN A SERIO AND FIRM WAY.
>> IS T JUST OUR HEMISPHERE
PELE ARE COMING IN FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD RIGHTOW BECAUSE
THE BORDER IS OPEN AND IGAIN I
THINK IF YOU FOCUS MORE ON
SECURI YOUR BORDER ASPPOSED
TO INVESTING MONEY IN THE
CENTRAL TRIANGLE REALLY BETT
OFF AND I THINK...
IF YOU TAKE ALL THE TALENT OUT
OF THIS COUNT WHO'S LEFT
ACTUALLY REBUILD THE CNTRY TO
HAVE AN ECONOMY.
>> Jeanine: CAN YOU GO RIGHT
AHEAD?
>> THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
[LAUGHS]
>> LOOK AND A CONGRESSIONALOFFIS
PEOPLE WHO ARE MEAN THEY YELL AT
THE STAFF PEOPLE WHO WERE
INEFFECTIVE.
YOU SEE THE STAFF FLOOD OUT OF
THOSE OFFIC AND IT'S A
REVOLVING DOORF MY COMMISSION
WHO THEY ARE BUT WE A KNOW
THOSE OFFICES OF HORRIBLE
SSES.
BUT ALSO YOU SEE STAFF WANT TO
CONSOLIDATE AROUND POWER OR
CHAIAN.
THE VICERESIDENT IS A REALLY
POWERFUL POSITION ITHE STAFF
HAS MORE POWER THAT E BOSS
HAS.
SO YOU SEE PPLE LEAVING
KAMALA HARRIS' OFFICE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT THAT SHOWS REALLY
HOW BAD IT IS AND I THINK PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY WANT TO HAVE A
REPUTION.
THEY SEE HOW BAD HE IS AND HOW
WE CAN'T PUT SENTENCES AND
PARAGRAPHS TOGETHER EVERYTHING
SHE'S BEEN DIVERED AS A POLICY
PRIORITYHE CAN GET DONE.
TWO IMPORTANT TO ME HIM ANDTEP
BACK I DON'T WANT ANY
KAMALA HARRIS ONE DON'T PUT
THAT TAPE ON ME.
I' OUT.
>> Jeanine: SHE DOESN CARE
FOR HER STAFF THAT SHE DOES FOR
E PEOPLE OF THE COUNTRY IS THE
WAY THAT SHE'S HANDLING THE
BORDER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A COUPLE
SECURITY CHIEF OF STAFF THIS
HAPPEN.
THESE ARE TOUGH JS.
I THINK IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK
AT THE NUMBERS YOU BE SURPRISED.
>> Jeanine: LOOK AT E
NUMBERS WHERE YOU NODDING?
Greg: THERE IS A LOT OF
TURNOVER THE TRIPD
ADMINISTRATION.
THE POINT IS WAS A DIFFERENT
REASON FOR TURNOVER THAN THIS.
IT DIDN'T HA TO DO A TRUMPET
AT A DO WITHHE ONSLAUGHT OF
THE MEDIA COVERAGE AND JUST THE
CONSTANT HARASSMENT FM THE
OUIDE.
>> OR THE VICE PRESIDT.
SHE'S LOST A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF
HER STAF